this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they love
create actual amazing relationships
we're here to help you do all of that
rachel cruz ramsey personality number
one best-selling author and my daughter
is my co-host today open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
five
two two five dakota is with us to start
this hour in san antonio hi dakota how
are you
hi i'm good thank you so much for taking
my call sure what's up
so i wanted to see if i could get a
little bit of guidance from y'all um i
live with my boyfriend and we have a
baby together
um but we do not have our finances
combined um i bring debt into our
relationship he does not have any debt
um so i'm currently working on the baby
steps um using the snowball and um have
been trying to knock that out but we do
have quite a few shared finances
um like we pay for my 50 50 for my
daughter's daycare 50 50 for rent
groceries all that stuff so we're
constantly like been mowing or writing
each other checks or things like that to
reimburse
and so it's just gonna be do you
recommend continuing to keep our
finances separate until i knock out the
rest of our debt of my debt or should we
go ahead and combine them to make our
everyday expenses easier
so dakota why don't y'all just get
married
um because i
have a lot of guilt about having the
debt and i want to knock it out before
we get married
so you're waiting
for marriage to pay off your debt
yes
okay i would encoura i would encourage
you i would not wait i wouldn't wait and
i would encourage people
who want to get married not to they
don't have to wait i think even having a
baby you don't need to wait to have a
baby until you're debt-free
uh that this debt i wouldn't say i think
that that's a
that's kind of a separate thing i know
what what makes you feel guilty about it
just the fact that you guys would
combine finances when you get married
and you are going to take you guys
backwards is that it
right yeah and um he does have like a
much larger income than i do
and so i just would hate for there to be
any like resentment or animosity about
um
me bringing in debt when he doesn't have
any has he
kind of alluded to that is that a little
bit of kind of his immo or is that are
you
playing that tape in your head just out
of yourself probably
more of the latter yeah he's never
eluded
yeah dakota how old are you
i am 26. okay
um
this guy's in love with you
you have a baby with him
you sleep with him
you live with him
and you're trying to figure out how to
combine incomes
and combine everything but do all of
that without combining the debt
too late
that ship has sailed
rachel's right
i'm gonna put my old man arm around you
and give you a hug
and say honey
best thing for that baby
best thing for this man
best thing for you is get married and
then combine your incomes combine your
lives combine everything
join it together so tight that it cannot
be torn us under and then go live a
beautiful glorious life
okay and getting out of debt is part of
the adventure raising the child is part
of the adventure
uh waking up and looking at him when he
starts to lose his hair is part of the
adventure
okay
all right awesome well thank y'all so
much for your help and then
see here's the problem it's legally and
relationally very difficult
to financially play house
when you're not married
because you get into this argument over
the mustard
who bought the mustard and yet you're in
the same bed it's just it's it's so
inconsistent and incongruent it's just
weird and awkward and that's just a part
of the the system that you're using is
all and it's not a judgment thing you
didn't hear judgment in our voices we
just want good things for you we love
you we love you and we love that baby
and we want you guys to have a wonderful
life
and so
um i i i would uh
take that tape out of your head and i
would wad it up and throw it away that
somehow you've done
something wrong by bringing the debt to
the table for god's sakes baby is a ten
debt is a one on a scale of one to ten
okay
relationships ten marriage is a ten
on a debt is a small thing if you're
both in agreement that that this debt is
a bad thing and we're going to clear it
as fast as we can using all of our
combined marital incomes and assets and
so that we can have a wonderful glorious
life for this baby and as a couple then
you're going to knock that debt out so
fast it's silly and uh it's blocking you
from having your best possible wonderful
glorious life yeah it's hard to work as
a team when you're legally not a team
and you're having to go around all this
stuff so it's just hard guys are doing
great it's hard to do finances with your
roommate it just is it's just it's it's
yeah you know you can't act like you're
married with your finances
when you're acting like you're married
with every other part of your life it's
just it's so awkward and weird and it's
hard and i'm not saying you're awkward
and weird i'm just saying this is the
way it works it's very difficult hey
thanks for the call very very good
question
you know a lot of people uh
living together that aren't married have
that exact question we've had it over
the years a lot
the other issue is is that there's all
kinds of data out there in the world and
this is not for dakota but this is just
generally on this discussion
that um
they call it the poverty cycle or the
poverty indicators
that there's about three or four poverty
indicators that if you get if you have a
baby before you're married again not not
messing with dakota here but i'm just
giving you the poverty poverty
indicators
uh if you um
uh
get married before graduating from high
school
or uh or start living with someone
before you graduate from high school uh
if um you know and we keep going on the
levels of education uh all these
different things all of these things are
indicators
that that you know you're 90 more likely
i have to pull the study up i can't
remember the details but you're 90 more
likely to live before the poverty level
below the poverty level if you don't do
these things that are really social
indicators of what's going on in your
life because what happens is it's very
difficult to prosper for financially
when you're 17 years old with a baby
yeah well for sure yeah but i think even
more than that the stuff that i've seen
in research within the marriage aspect
of the rate of divorce is higher of
those that live together yeah so for me
i'm like you know there's there's a um
probably a spiritual conviction that
that we have with this but they're also
after over the years of seeing people do
this like you said just kind of playing
house
there's a commitment level there in a
marriage that has to be there um and it
affects your outcome financially yes and
when it's not there right and that's
what i'm saying is like the the
tentacles play in it's just like when
people come in with a with a marriage a
money question about marriage so well my
spouse won't get on the same page the
tentacles are just the money but there's
so much underneath that and so pressing
this generation it sounds great oh well
i'll see if we like each other enough to
live together the living together is a
small portion of it it is it's the
marriage commitment that you that that
is the greatest weight and that weight
has been taken away from this generation
is what it feels like to me yeah yeah
it's now you sound like an old person
[Music]
from this
worry about this generation
for 12 years don't worry about the
generation unbelievable those are
ginseers those little puppies oh god
bless them
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
i'm so excited
orlando
we hope you're ready
we're going to be down there a week from
thursday on may the 19th for our
building wealth live event if you
haven't gotten your seats yet you're
missing out there's only about 3 000
seats and we have sold almost 3 000 you
can still get tickets gonna be an
action-packed night george camel rachel
cruz
dr john delony ken coleman and i are
hosting
this real event
in person human beings in a room
building wealth live event and dr john
dolan and ken coleman will be doing a
free bonus session about work and
relationships before the main event
afterwards everybody be signing books
and taking pictures and hanging out
meeting you guys we're so excited to do
this tickets are only 25 each orlando
one week for this coming thursday may
the 19th you can bring your friends it's
only 60 for a four pack that's four
people for 15 bucks ahead this is a deal
it's going to be a lot of fun and then
this fall we're going to be in phoenix
in sacramento in minneapolis and in san
antonio
all of those have sold almost 2 000
tickets already and the
event venues range from two to three
thousand people so
if you uh in terms of what they hold so
if you want to come to any of those even
in the fall i suggest you go ahead and
get them done those are in september
13th november 1st 10th and 15th are the
is the fall tour it's going to be a lot
of fun rachel las vegas the other night
was on fire oh so fun
so fun they were a great crowd they they
were and it was orlando you're gonna
have to bring it to keep up with vegas
well and the it always shocks me which
happens all the events but since we just
haven't done one i feel like in years it
feels like 20 years the amount of um
traveling that people do
you know around so lots of people from
l.a and
orange county and i mean all you know um
they're called regions right away it's
like it's a suburb though it's not that
far right no they do yeah but anyways it
was it was so fun but great people great
people yeah it was it was a lot of fun
we had just under 3 000 folks there just
over 3 000 something like that is a big
audience
laughing and uh carrying on together and
it's just good to be around people that
have good sense and
man our audiences are just they're good
people i mean they are they're great
people we don't have a bunch of crazies
in our audiences they're good folk
and uh they just want to get better they
want to do better they want to be around
other people it kind of normalizes
wisdom yeah you know because there's so
so little wisdom in our culture today
so uh yeah come hang out with the real
people yeah
the crazies are all on tv
oh my gosh that's nuts all right zach is
with us zach in atlanta hi zach how are
you
good how are you better than i deserve
what's up
uh it's a quick question i have uh
about 8 500 in credit cards between two
credit card debts
and a vehicle with
a vehicle with 23 000 which is paid for
through my company every month so that's
kind of besides the point but no it's
not my question is
okay well i i got you but the the main
reason i was calling was should i
combine the two credit cards and get a
personal loan
with a lower interest rate to pay off
the credit cards
okay what do you make
uh
65
okay
well we teach folks zack if you are new
to our stuff to be extremely intense
unbelievably focused
cut your lifestyle to nothing
scorched earth
no life yes until you clear these debts
have you heard that stuff said by ramsey
people before
oh absolutely okay that's what i've been
listening here lately now given that as
our scenario making 65 000 how fast are
you going to pay off 8 500.
should be fast well what's fast
uh if i if i do the budgeted app like
i'm i'm working on which the first month
didn't go as planned like i'll talk
about um
six months okay good all right and so
really what we're discussing with your
question then is interest rate on eight
thousand dollars for six months
ten percent change
for one year would be an 800 change
so a 10 change in interest rate
by getting a different loan
on 8 500 is a 400 dollar swing
follow me all right okay i said and 400
is nice if you send it to me rachel will
cash the check
i'll take it
okay
but the uh you see but here's my here's
my point okay the reason we're doing
this math out is this
it's okay to do what you're talking
about doing
the problem with it is it makes you feel
like you did something
right but you still have the debt well
yeah you what you did was 400
and you don't have a 400 problem you
have a 31 000 problem
right and so
you know and you've already ascertained
you listen you're already ahead of the
curve because you've already figured
this out i'm doing my budget didn't work
right the first month i'm learning how
to do this i'm building new muscles that
i didn't have before you're on you're on
track to be winning with this zack
you're very impressive
so but what i'm pointing out is is that
the math
says the important thing to work on is
living on nothing and paying this debt
off super fast because that's eight
thousand dollars in six months
the question you asked about is 400
dollars in six months so if you only do
the 400 change you didn't do anything
right
you do the 8 000 change and you don't do
the 400 change you're still out of debt
right so you're the secret sauce not the
interest rate because it's such a short
term and it's such a
small amount of money in general as in
the scope of your life and where you're
going to see the momentum zach is not
just in the math which is what we're
doing right so the idea of taking well
should i just take a personal loan to
you know combine the credit cards and
just have one loan with lower interest
all that's like it's math talk but when
you get in that change of wow i am i'm
literally sacrificing my lifestyle i am
saying no to things and i'm throwing
money at it that's the momentum that's
what's going to get you to win
long term and to pay this off it's not
going to be the math and you can do that
and that's the problem is i think we get
so caught up in the math and we think
about money so your question is not
um invalid because it's like oh yeah
that makes sense if we're just talking
about math but we're not talking about
math in order to completely change the
way you handle money and to build wealth
over the long term it's your behavior
that changes and so by you saying
this little math of 400
i don't even i'm not even going to mess
with because i'm going to focus so much
on what i can do
and changing you know your budget
putting money away and i mean going
through the baby steps that's where
you're going to see a lot of progress i
sense that you're going to be making
more than the minimum payments that i
have right you're going to keep the debt
if you were going to keep the debt for
five years then it would be a big deal
to get the personal life right
but you're not right so yeah so you're
already convinced but let me keep
teaching our audience with your example
okay
um the uh the other thing is this the
words that we use all of us
reveal what is going on in our heart and
you said something very interesting that
i want you to think about
because personal finance is behavior
more than it is math you said i want to
get a personal loan to pay off my two
credit cards well you're really not
paying them off you're just moving them
to a personal life
so a proper way of saying it would have
been hey i want to move my debt over to
a different kind of debt to get a lower
interest rate but i'm going to pay off
my debt
with extremely low lifestyle and a debt
snowball
and that's how i'm going to pay off the
debt because you can't borrow your way
out of debt and so that's a lesson for
the rest of our audience because people
say that all the time i'm going to pay
off my debt by borrowing this no you
didn't pay it off you just moved it and
so again all this to say the budget i
think the budget would be the first step
before i'm even worried about doing the
personal loan evidently because the
budget didn't work the first that's
right yeah let's get going and really
get some momentum on on pounding that 8
500 in the mouth just beat the snot out
of it right and then when you get then
when you get that moving like you're
saying uh if you want to do the personal
loan and save 400 like i said that's
that's good there's nothing wrong with
400 but if you feel like that got you
out of debt then you were mathematically
wrong what gets you out of debt is zach
looking in the mirror and go hey bubba
we're changing
that's a big deal and paying off that
smallest credit card first by keeping
them separate
gives you that momentum as well of like
okay i can do this it's actually working
and it keeps you fueled yeah versus one
one big loan that's true you lose the
moment the emotional momentum of the
debt snowball by moving it yeah the dead
snowball is where do you know where that
is do you know what the death star well
is i love it i've heard of it i'll teach
you the next segment don't worry okay
thank you up to date on how to use it i
will i'll teach you that's so you're so
kind this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free stage
jacob and dree is it dre dread dread i'm
sorry drea is with us where do you guys
live
yeah nashville
all right
now i understand from kelly that you
guys have a unique approach to getting
out of debt a unique situation
tell us tell us your story before we ask
about the debt okay um yeah i mean
essentially at the time we were just a
couple boyfriend and girlfriend and i
had asked him very early on we were
really vulnerable and open about where
we stood financially um you know what
our financial status was
and
so it made the conversation really easy
when i asked him like you know for like
our future like should we get married
things like that like what do you want
to see from that
and um i had asked him if he had heard
of you
i was familiar i knew your name yeah
baby steps but that was about it never
practiced any of it yeah and
i had actually started the journey back
in 2019 um because my friends dan and
michelle had actually introduced me to
you as well as the baby steps and
subsequently gifted me financial peace
university oh wow yeah and you were all
in i was so all-in okay so how much debt
did you start with well at that time
because i ended up relapsing oh okay
i ended up relapsing um so at that point
i think it was like 18 000 i can't quite
remember but at that point it was that i
relapsed
um
and so once we got together and started
talking more about it i you know asked
wait a minute wait wait wait you drove
right by you flunked financial peace
university
and
but it's it's a class you can't flunk
you just get to do it again okay so how
much were you how much debt were you in
at that point i was in eighteen thousand
got up to the point where i all i had
left was my student loan now however
that was right when coveted hit and when
the fourth part when you all are having
this discussion you had
eighteen thousand not at that point this
was before we got together oh okay she's
here from the beginning from the
beginning
i'm telling you we're all over there
thank you okay i'm just i'll catch up in
a minute you gotta help me draft okay
now so the
at the point you're having this
discussion and we're getting real you
said you had how much debt well at the
point that we got together i had twenty
four thousand dollars that's what i'm
after yes so you start this portion of
the journey with 24. the portion of the
journey where you all are dating and
it's going to lead towards marriage
okay yeah and uh what about you jacob at
this point in the relationship where
you're leading how much debt did you
have 18 000 okay all right and so now we
have the discussion and we start these
individual tracks right you like i got
to know what these baby steps are
because this girl's bugging me about it
yeah
kind of it was a very fluid conversation
he was really open to the idea because
again i'd kind of dave i've kind of gone
through it before
um so you know i was already familiar
and already knew what that entailed and
so when i was telling him about it he
was all on board it made sense it was
just like oh this yeah this is way to
get out of this let's do it right so i
started asking him like you know would
you want to just do this like
accountability blades would you want to
do this alongside me because one of the
things that we knew from the get-go was
that we did not want to introduce the
number one cause of divorce into our
marriage when that time came and so we
had to make sure we were on the same
page with that right and so we and we
were we were very wise yeah very watched
there was never any kind of like hiccup
or any kind of you know head butting
with that so
i'm the nerd
the relationship
and so i started to kind of buckle down
with like okay like if you you know if
you kept with your journey and i kept
with mine here's where we could be
and at that point we would have been
debt-free by our anniversary which is in
june next month so we're like okay six
months like your dating anniversary yes
right okay so all right yeah so we were
like okay like that would be cool like
what a way to celebrate
um but i'm psychotic and so i was like
wait a minute
um
i was like you know we have a friend's
wedding that was coming up in march at
that point and i was like what if we did
it by the wedding and at that point it
was going to be 100 days so we were
cutting it in half
his eyes he gave that look
i was like we just cut this in half and
uh and so he was a little bit weary
about it and so i
again kind of rewrote it down i was like
look if we pick up a couple of side
hustles and we really get at it
we can do this like i i really feel
confident that we can do this and so
once because i want to get married i'm
ready for it
no i mean of course i mean who wouldn't
but but it was more of just like we can
get out of this because again i had
dragged it out i had relapsed he's been
through his own situation which you know
he may share and so
once i presented him with the plan of
like look we can get this done in a
hundred days
it was game on yeah which is worth the
plan so you did the whole thing in a
hundred days we did the whole thing in
1720
oh my gosh yeah you all are psychotic i
love you
legitimately i love it okay so you're
amazing what did that what are those 70
one date what did that look like
sleepless yeah yeah legitimately about
legitimately sleepless we so what side
hustles because we both did essentially
the same things to get there which is
why we were able to start and end at the
exact same time
um so essentially what the days kind of
looked like we would get up around 2 30
or so in the morning and go side hustle
until 8 a.m when our full-time job
started would do our full-time jobs from
eight until five and then we would side
hustle again until about 11 p.m at night
yeah and then just repeat wash around
repeat for 71 days what was the
the best paying side hustle you did oh
what that um amazon amazon delivering
delivering for yourself
delivered to your house who knows who
knows you probably did
a higher probability you delivered to
rachel's
i know i love amazon so yeah that was
that was probably the the most
especially because we did it during the
holidays we started to go you guys okay
so now you're officially married or
engaged
we're getting married on our anniversary
next month
oh okay well that'll help everybody know
what the anniversary is going forward
okay yeah
super simple can't screw it up if it's
one day this is awesome way to go you
guys
that's amazing man i'm so proud of you
thank you you were smart and that wise
and that you weren't married you did not
combine your finances instead you just
encouraged each other but you were so in
sync it was almost as if combined
because you were game only which was
kind of awesome because again whenever
almost a competition a little bit it
literally was because it was one morning
i decided i was gonna sleep in a little
bit that day i was gonna sleep until 4
30.
instead of getting up at three slacker i
know and that's essentially what you
said slacker she goes i'm going out to
deliver it calls me she goes i'm going
out to deliver i go
all right i guess i am too here we go
calling out your manhood man exactly
you're sleeping in you slacker yeah you
know but
but it's been such a cool thing too
because you know now we're each on baby
step three and what we've realized and
learned is that we will have our
completed emergency fund by the time
we're married so we're just starting our
marriage off on like the best foot
finally you guys are fun thank you y'all
are gonna have a blast you're gonna be
so wealthy and you're gonna have so much
fun doing it oh we know yeah i mean we
listening to your show helps us realize
where we're gonna be because listening
to other people's debt-free screams and
just the success that they've had has
really helped us kind of
visualize it and go after it okay so let
me ask this real quick i want to veer
off from the from the death ray but real
quick how was planning a wedding with
cash because we get this call a lot yeah
we uh we're cash flowing the entire
thing and we actually run it out because
we're having a very intimate wedding um
out in wine country california because
that's where i'm from i'm from
california so um and so that's just kind
of my dream and we rented out the whole
inn and paid for because we're having
everyone stay with us and so we paid for
half of their room so they don't have to
worry about so we're cash flowing
everything right on top of our merchants
it makes it easy that's amazing
destination wedding people say i can't
pay for a wedding if i don't have it but
you guys are literally cash flowing yeah
and you know we talk about a lot we talk
about a lot how much our mindset has
just shifted since starting this
you know and accomplishing this like
together but you know because there is a
sense of togetherness when we have the
same share y'all are fun this is great
we got a copy of baby steps millionaires
for you because that's the next chapter
in your story we also got a gift card
for you to ramsey plus which is
financial peace university every dollar
for a year yes that's going to be a
great wedding gift or you can give it
away to a friend if bridesmaid if you
want yeah that kind of thing very cool
stuff and a copy of total money makeover
i know you're going to give that away
and that's why we give it to you so you
i've got my copies and he started so
we're on it you guys you guys are
wonderful so fun thank you thank you for
sharing your story you give inspiration
all the singles out there they're trying
to figure out how to navigate this whole
process jacob andrea in nashville did it
as two singles now getting married
wonderful 24 and 18 000 paid off in 71
days all they did was work count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream
three two one
[Applause]
they are fabulous aren't they fun
they just had a handshake you missed it
they did that
they're funny it's great this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
five
four
three
[Music]
so
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
carlos is in houston hey carlos welcome
to the ramsey show
hi how you doing
better than we deserve sir how can we
help
um all right well i have a couple
questions but i just kind of want to
keep it short um i've been
watching your shows and i actually
started reading your books um not too
long ago so i've been kind of uh diving
into watching all your shows pretty
consistently lately
even through lunches like right now but
i have a little bit of that well a lot
of debt that i have to try to take care
of and uh it all kind of started a long
story short about three years ago during
uh colgod right before koben i purchased
my house
i got a new car
and
we had gotten kind of
i know it sounds kind of dumb but based
off all your videos you know can we kind
of fell into a time share
um but it didn't really seem like it was
until a month later when we tried to get
out and it was impossible since then
i've kind of been stuck in that for you
know coming up to two three years now we
went through so much trouble um i mean
with a lot of details left out we went
through lots of headaches and stress
trying to get out of it and um i
actually got out of the job that i was
currently in that was kind of uh getting
damaged by coleridge so now i'm at a job
where i'm consistent but i just really
want your advice on how to
get out of this debt work to kind of get
started
i kind of have an idea but
um
i did refinance that time share into a
personal loan um almost immediately
after we did it to save on interest to
save on payments i just didn't want to
be paying too much
but now i'm still stuck with that debt
that after years of contacting them and
calling and and just getting misled
doesn't seem like i'm going to get out
of it so i'm really wanting to see
how i can get rid of all this debt and
what's the best scenario um as best so
how much debt do you have carlos
all right so not counting the mortgage
um i have about 72 thousand vehicles
between me and my wife um 20 000
in loans
and 10 000 in credit card okay what's
your household income
uh 75 000 okay you got to sell some cars
fine
yeah like all of them
yes sir
and that's kind of ironic just listening
to your show today even it kind of
pinpointed different questions
throughout the collins and now coming to
my situation that's kind of what i've
been thinking about a lot like i've kind
of figured if i call mr ramsey you know
he's gonna he's gonna tell me that's the
first thing he's gonna tell me so
it's just something that i kind of
wanted some help on yeah so here's the
thing
uh 75
of your debt
is car debt
we can get rid of three quarters of your
problem
selling two used cars that you can't
afford
problem is you love them and they're
beautiful wonderful cars
yes sir yeah what are they
yes sir
and uh what kind of cars are they for
it's a forerunner and a
you
tacoma
get great money from that though carlos
thank you the great music the great news
is they're probably going to sell for
more than you owe
that's actually kind of what i was going
to bring up is i went to a dealer not
too long ago seeing the stress of
everything that happened throughout the
years and they actually offered for my
truck uh 46 000
and it's been kind of haunting me in my
head even though as much as i feel like
i can't find this truck again i kind of
wanted to
rely on your advice
and i figured i could just get rid of it
i mean i even thought you know just to
simply show that truck for what they
want get something that's 20 000 less i
could probably put all that into the
personal loans pay that off and use it
what do you owe on that car
uh forty thousand okay well you can't
get something twenty thousand dollars
less you could get something forty
thousand dollars less
we're getting out of that not into debt
so you would be your advice would be to
remove both of them not just one yeah i
kind of wanted to keep
them yeah i'd get rid of all of them
listen you don't need to if you own
things with wheels and motors that equal
more than half your annual income you
got too much invested in things that are
going down in value the only time cars
have gone up in value in the history of
the freaking world is in the last five
months
prior to that they've gone down in value
every year and they will again as soon
as the supply catches up with the demand
and the new cars are starting to hit the
lots again so it's just a matter of time
this is the best time in the world to
get out of a dead gum used car mess and
son you got to use car mess you got to
get out of these things and so carlos
too you know it's it's buying a crappy
five thousand dollar car somewhere yep
and you both drive that but for a short
period of time carlos that's what when
you said oh but i don't know if i can
get this kind of truck again you can i
promise tacomas will be made and you may
it may take you three four years to get
it but you can get another car another
great car that you love again but right
now it's not worth it it's not worth it
the stress
and the pain that these have caused you
guys already
it's not worth it so getting rid of that
and
i think it's fun to illustrate this so
you're right he will get something again
so
carlos when i went through this myself
it was a long time ago
but uh i was down to one car and a
friend loaned me
a 1978 cadillac with 478 000 actual
miles on it and the predominant color on
the thing was bondo
it was a piece of crap
it was a car that was embarrassing
anywhere in town even in the worst
neighborhoods in town
they laughed at you in every stoplight
driving this car
i drove that car for three months and i
saved up a thousand dollars and got a
considerably better car
this morning i drove in on a classic
1960 corvette that i bought that is one
of several automobiles that i own if you
will drive like no one else later you
can drive anything you want to drive sir
so i'm not bragging i'm just saying that
what i've been doing this a long time
and
i when i was driving that piece of crap
car
i thought the world was coming to an end
and i kind of thought about that car
this morning with the top down on that
corvette driving to work i thought you
know if you live like no one else later
you can live and drive
like no one else this stuff we teach
works over the time that's it and that
came from after being in a nice car
yeah that you were in yeah i was driving
a jaguar i just think i don't know why
i don't know why your your daughter's
heart just kind of giggles that a jaguar
was like the thing it wasn't a mercedes
but a jaguar
i don't know why mercedes a lot of
people hadn't nobody had a jacket oh is
that what it was it was the unique
jaguars were exotic okay okay so the
jaguar 1981 just saying it
redneck says jaguar i mean it's like a
thing you know
these are these are words that don't
roll off of a
off of a redneck's lips first what year
was it
it was the first one was a um yeah an
80. okay so 1980 you are
you're not carlos carson i'm not pinning
you like aim to go from what you want i
sold that to keep it from to go into
bondo car i was going broke painful so
carlos was here i went from a super nice
car yep a nicer car in those days than
you've got today yes into a piece of
absolute trash so that wasn't even mine
it was loaned to me yes so carlos
prepare for the pain driving the crappy
car for a little bit
but it's worth it for a short period of
time
to get on the other side to get what you
want i did that for three months that's
right but telling the story right now
my stomach kind of hurts still it was
painful it was awful it felt i always
say i did that for 10 years one three
month period because that's how it felt
like it felt like it was forever
because i mean when everybody laughs at
you at every stop light there's a lot of
shame involved
you know i just wonder who laughs at
people in cars like you haven't seen
this car this car this you would laugh
at this car if you saw it at a stop i
mean it's just i mean and you're a sweet
person but it's like you look at that
and you go this poor guy yeah i mean he
must be homeless it looks awful how does
he drive that car it's horrible
and the bondo or the vinyl roof was torn
loose across the top so when you feel
drove it it filled up there so it looked
like that was the kind of car we grew up
in those guys what was the brown car you
all had when we were kids that was a
mark seven houses later on man i
remember driving into the like drop
schools drop off line and that thing the
it would bubble up
and you had to like push it up no that
was the headliner did not the top top
on top would fill up there like you had
a parachute on top of your car oh no it
was so bad no that was the headliner in
that old brown one i've forgotten that
and it would like rest on our heads and
be like yeah for about a week and then i
fixed it but yeah i forgot about that
that did happen i remember that that's
the car i delivered books out of the
trunk the first financial piece the
brown car had a little hump on the trunk
it was a 1985 mark seven what's that so
carlos look your future is bright your
car future is bright carlos you can do
this you can do this
all this to say
the cars are temporary
cars are temporary they're not forever
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey it's rachel cruz co-host on the
ramsay show if you want to do your debt
free stream live on the show visit
ramsey
ramseysolutions.com
debt free screen we'd love for you to
come to nashville and tell dave your
story that's ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
this is the ramsey show where we help
people build wealth do work that they
love
and create amazing actual relationships
rachel cruz ramsey personality number
one best-selling author and my daughter
is my co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life and your money
troy is with us at triple eight eight
two five five two two five he's in
sacramento hi troy how are you
i'm doing great thanks for asking and
thanks dave and thanks rachel for taking
my call this afternoon sure how can we
help
you know my wife and i have been big
fans and we've followed a lot of your
teachings and precepts over the years
and it's allowed us to
come to a place of having no debt other
than a little bit left over on a
on a primary mortgage
we'd like to move
out of sacramento
and my question directly is
if we paid off our home that would be
would be debt free and be great then we
would be freed up to invest more and
more into either retirements or other
investment opportunities
my question is do you ever consider
a larger mortgage like buying a more
expensive home or the more expensive
area as your primary residence
as an investment vehicle rather than
using the money and investing in say the
stock market
well the problem with that is that um
you're violating the rule of
diversification
because then you've got so much tied up
in one asset
so let me give you an example as we're
studying the uh ten thousand
millionaires in the ramsey study of
millionaires
when we would run across one and they
were very rare but occasionally we would
run across one that was a millionaire
maybe their net worth is a million two
but their paid for home is a million one
well they're legitimately a millionaire
i mean their net worth is over a million
dollars but that's a little scary
because they're not diversified and that
asset does not create an income for them
at retirement
right it creates a place for them to
live
and so they could live in a six hundred
thousand dollar paid for house and have
six hundred thousand dollars with a
million two in other words invested
creating income
and so the
while the home is an asset it's not an
income producing asset
right
so you know in our situation our
retirement 401k is just shy of a million
dollars you know that our daughter's
colleges
you know we've saved and we have that
essentially taken care of with
scholarships that they've received
you know we've got the emergency fund
put in place we've got cash in the bank
the current home value that we have is
about 575 and we owe about 170 000 on it
and
and so we you know we feel like we've
got a good base we could continue doing
that pay off the house and so what price
range home would you be in with your
investment concept that you're pitching
well it's just it's right around a
million dollars
and so you know a 30-year old so you're
currently at 1617 net worth right
um right in there and you'd have a
million of it in your home
uh if we went down that road yeah yeah
yeah that's a little high that's a
little high that makes me a little
nervous it's not it's not it's not over
in the stupid column it's just the
nervous approaching stupid column
it's not it's not even saying that
because my wife is listening on the
other side not even close to stupid okay
i'm joking around with you you guys are
brilliant you're millionaires way to go
congratulations i'm so proud of you
you've done a lot of things right so all
we're doing is just discussing the fact
that um you're gonna have uh what uh
60
of your net worth tied up in non-income
producing assets i'll give you another
example right now i'll give you another
example that okay i've got a 250 acre
farm
that is that does absolutely nothing
except hold the earth together and as a
place for me to shoot guns and drive
four-wheelers it does not create any
income
it's worth millions of dollars okay but
it does not create any income if that
was the larger portion of my total net
worth
that would be unwise
because it really is a receptacle for
bullets and four-wheelers that's really
all it does it doesn't create anything
for me to live off of and so even though
it's a wonderful investment because it's
going it's in a it's in a prime location
it's it's in one of the fastest growing
counties in the nation you know it's
it's wonderful ground but as you know
some day when some ramsay sells it it
won't be while i'm alive but while some
ramsey sells it they will do very well
on it but it's not an income producer so
that's the whole that's the whole
discussion and you guys just got to
balance that out in your minds and go
okay and what is our income and how much
can we add to the 700 000 of income
producing assets if we do this so that
it's less and less and less and less out
of balance it starts to bother me
what percentage because like you said 60
there but what's the yeah i mean when
you get north of 50 it's start to be
scary
you got a million two and a half of it's
in a house that's not too bad as long as
you're adding to your investments right
yeah um but i i'm but again it would
change it skews
the percentages would skew as you go way
up too so let's say you had a 20 million
dollar net worth why wouldn't you be
anywhere near that in your personal
residence sure yes you know maybe maybe
uh 1 20th 5 would be a million dollar
house yeah or a 2 million house would be
10 with a 20 million net worth but you
shouldn't be sitting around a 10 million
dollar house with a 20 that would be
ridiculous yeah you know
you can do it but i just don't think
it'd be wise yes
and so uh
in my mind it would be ridiculous and
and you're in i'm just going to go step
further because what you're saying
though it's
mostly majority because there's not an
income producing element to it it's not
that like
the house is going to be taking it like
it's not like it's a risky thing because
it's there if he dies what's his wife
going to eat on yeah she can't eat the
bushes in front of the house right
no matter how valuable they are she got
to sell the house in order to liquidate
to get money
and i don't want her to have to do that
i want her to be able to live
comfortably on the income producing
portion of the portfolio
that that's what that's what's running
through my head it's they're okay as
long as they're sitting there right now
if everything stays the same he keeps
creating we don't even ask what his
income is but i'm sure it's great
i mean and he's a smart guy they're
gonna do fine they're they're smart
people they're there's really not a
horrible answer in this whole thing but
that
and so you know let's say let's pretend
they make 300 000 and they're gonna have
no house payment and they're gonna be in
a million so that house is pretty well
it's gonna go up in value it's
california real estate but uh but
it's not what they're dependent on in
other words they're going to take a 150
of that two of that 300 start throwing
and adding to that 700
in 10 years
this thing will really not be out of
whack at all yeah as long as he doesn't
die as long as he doesn't quit it
working as long as that income doesn't
go away and we don't complete the plan
but if you stop early in the plan you
might have to liquidate the house that's
what that's kind of i want things to
work when they don't work and when they
do work yeah or the plan to have
addressed both sides of the equation and
that's that's all i'm
wincing about when we're talking about
this but yeah and so
yeah
the
overall idea too is diversification
spread your portions to seven years to
eight for disaster may come upon the
land
that's a biblical reference from
ecclesiastes don't put all your eggs in
one basket
some do will cause a pandemic to happen
or
go crazy when a pandemic does happen or
something and then you'll be there there
you'll be in that mess again
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
all right rachel if i gave you three
thousand dollars right now what would
you do with it i play crafts in vegas
i'm just kidding
where am i no what would i do 3 000
right now seriously yeah
[Music]
um
oh my gosh i would probably go
buy something yeah i'd give some away
yeah i would save some
and then i would go you're trying to
give the right answer is that what
you're doing
all right so
giving me 3 000 or no it's one of the
best times of the year at ramsey we're
not giving you 3 000 but we're giving
one of our listeners three thousand
dollars oh that's pretty fun and five
hundred dollars a week in may and a
grand prize of three thousand dollars in
the ramsey cash giveaway to enter the
ramsey cash giveaway go to
ramseysolutions.com
giveaway don't forget you can enter
every day for extra chances to win there
is absolutely no purchase necessary but
you must be 18 or older to win and we're
not stopping there to help you crush
your financial personal and professional
goals we're putting our number one
best-selling books and tools in the
ramsey 10
sale
in many cases that's 60 to 70 to even 80
off 10 bucks doesn't get you much
anymore but during the 10 sale you can
get stuff like the total money makeover
or rachel's book know yourself
know your money which can save you
thousands of dollars in debt problems
and everything else help put you on the
road to becoming a millionaire
it's a great return for 10 bucks
check out the ramsey 10 sale don't
forget to enter the ramsey cash giveaway
at
ramseysolutions.com ryan is in orlando
hey ryan welcome to the ramsay show
super dave how you doing sir better than
i deserve what's up
hey i just you know first of all i just
appreciate you and rachel taking my
phone call
and uh i i got to give a big uh shout
out to sharon
you know she she must be an amazing mom
and a wonderful wife sharon why don't
you tell her that she will pass that
along ryan and you were right she is how
can we help today
all right so um you know i've been
listening to the show the last couple
years and
you know i i've noticed you you know you
yourself had to kind of bob and weave a
little bit through the changes and you
know you've saved the course and and
things are going well and you know
you're an inspiration
so to get to the point you know
2019 was a tough year
i've been married the last couple years
prior to that
2019 my my wife left uh in november
after we paid off you know all her dead
and things of that nature
not a big deal march of 2020 i got the
divorce paperwork pandemic hit the whole
nine yards wow so
need to needless to say i i push pause
on the baby steps
um
just kind of focused on me mental health
and things of that nature
um wise
and increase my my uh my revenue done
really well
um
but now i'm at the point
you know the divorce was finalized last
year
uh in june and uh you know we're almost
at that year mark so i'm ready to push
play
and kind of get things rolling so
where i'm at right now i got 128 grand
in the bank
i have a rental house
i owe 84 grand
and it's got one of those stupid second
mortgages on it for 42 grand
so that's 126. i could literally get
that paid off
but the end of may my parents are
gifting me or blessing me with a car
which i'm giving them 10 grand for so
i'm about 8 grand short
the rental house that people are leaving
in august
so i guess i'm at that point now do i
could have all the money by july
should i wait
to get everything paid off until i get
renters back in the house
or should i go ahead and just push play
and keep that baby step emergency fund
because the house will be paid off
but i'll just be waiting to get a renter
in there
you have an emergency fund in addition
to the money you have you're the 128 in
the bank
just keeping the baby step the the the
one thousand dollars oh okay no okay you
don't have any debt but the rental
uh yeah i own a uh my regular house but
it's on wheels so i didn't want to bring
that up
okay all right but the uh uh
all right but you don't have any debt
other than real estate debt
that's it okay all of the real estate
debt falls into baby step six
well so i own a house that i live in
this is considered a rental house which
is baby step six
okay so
you know but you are going to go ahead
how much do you owe on the the house you
live in
it's 58
okay
i won't pay it off before i pay off the
rental
so you have 128 000 you have 128 000 in
the bank
and uh you need 10 grand to buy a car
and you need to have a fully funded
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses
and so
what would you what would your normal
fully funded emergency fund be how much
would that be
i i would probably like to keep it at 15
20. but it's really six months it's
probably seven eight grand well all
right let's let's call it uh let's call
it 20 for the fun of it for a minute
that leaves you 108 and you need 10 for
the half for the thing that leaves you
98
and then you pay off the one you live in
that leaves you 40 and so you could pay
off the second mortgage and the only
mortgage you'd have left is your first
mortgage on the rental if i did the math
right
you'd have the car an emergency fund
your residence would be paid off and the
second mortgage on the rental would be
paid off and you still have a little bit
to throw at the first mortgage but not
much
yeah and then just use your budget money
to begin to get that first mortgage paid
off
and uh what did you say you make a year
i'm i'm north of 100 right now i made
108 last year i'm on target there now
there were the kids in the marriage
no thank god no no kids okay all right
and so we made 112 together and she left
i got it up to 108 by myself so god is
good yeah yeah
so i knew you were gonna say that okay
um
i just think for me it's so much benefit
to get it paid off the rental house you
might show the house
the house is on wheels i might sell that
move too you might sell it too but at
least it's paid for for now yeah you get
money out of either one of them when you
sell them
we're not spending the money it's just a
matter where we're going to park it for
the most peace when the place you sleep
in is paid for it changes the way your
head hits the pillow
all right well i just i wanted a kick in
the rump i guess
i don't i don't i don't think you need
to go i i don't think you need a kick in
the rump i think you've had enough of
those
i think you're doing great ryan
i actually think you need a hug
yeah you sound like you're hurting man
i'm back involved in church and i love
my church and there's some great people
there so yeah i'm surrounded by it you
still got you you still got some sadness
hanging on you
yeah i do it's tough yeah i'm sorry i'm
sorry for what you've been through it's
been a hard hard season for you you uh
you you're a good man you got a big
heart and your heart was broken and it
takes courage around to press play again
i mean when you paused it you know which
i think was wise with what you were
walking through
to kind of tackle this again it take i
mean it takes a level of like okay i'm
gonna re-engage and that can be really
difficult so um i'm excited for you i
think you have great traction you
obviously
have an incredible work ethic you're
you're being wise and thinking through
all the steps and what to do
um but i think you're i think you're
gonna do great we'll send you a copy of
dr john's number one bestseller that
just hit the number one spot um own your
past change your future i think when you
read through that um it's going to help
your heart
and a lot of us have been through having
our hearts broken in different ways in
the last
36 months 24 months
and
so some much more tragic things than
others
certainly
but most people have experienced a
uh an increase in pain
during this time of one kind or another
and it's not unusual at all
for us to have some lingering sadness
from that some grief from all of that
and you just look back and you go what
in the world was i thinking well you
know you were sad
so the interesting thing is when you
start taking these actions with that
money instead of sitting on that money
like it's an egg
you're going to get some energy from
taking the actions
you know writing a check to mom and dad
get the car write out check pay off the
house with wheels pay off the second
mortgage
set that emergency fund aside in a
physical separate brand new account
that's just for emergencies never to be
touched or mixed with any other accounts
when you start making some of these
moves again the literal movement
will give you some energy back
but hang on kelly i'll pick up we're
gonna send you a copy of his book and
just want to know rachel and i are
hugging you right now brother this is
the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free stage robert
and crystal are with us hey guys how are
you doing well how are you here we
deserve welcome where do you guys live
just north of baltimore cool welcome to
nashville thank you and all the way here
to do a debt-free scream how much have
you paid off a little over 75 000 in
about 25 months good for you and your
range of income during that time
it was about 87 to 130. cool very good
good for you well done okay what kind of
debt was the 75 000
uh it was about 56 in student loans
we had 12 in a car uh five credit cards
and a small family loan ah okay cool
well what made you guys go on this
journey almost two years ago
well we moved to baltimore in 2013 and
that's when i started listening to your
show
it was after that
i started paying off my student loan
debt by myself
because we weren't married yet until
2015.
but even after 2015 we didn't combine so
i was still kind of paying my own off
and uh finally in july 2019 i
finally paid it off
and that was when she was like oh you
know maybe it's possible
so we were we took a trip up to uh my
parents for i think it was thanksgiving
that year end of 2019.
and uh
i was like let's listen to something on
the radio because haley was in the back
seat with a movie
and i was like but you know put the
ramsay show on she was like ah
and she's like all right let's put it on
so we listened to it she's like
listening to the people and she's like
oh we can do this
so we went on the trip we came we came
back and uh
we combined finally and uh we started
you know going on the journey
right at the beginning of 2020.
oh of course and then um
you know we pay off a few things the
credit cards first and she's like wow
that's not that difficult yeah and then
um
basically
with the credit cards just to throw that
out there i had two credit cards i was
paying 70 on one measly seventy dollars
and the other one was paying you know a
hundred dollars so when i paid seventy
dollars and then a little bit extra it
got quickly paid off and i go wait this
seventy dollars i can do i can buy more
clothes makeup
or i could put it towards the other
credit card and when i put that combined
with the 100 and the 70 dollars
it didn't seem like i was taking extra
money in my pocket and then all of a
sudden in three months that credit card
was paid off and so that's where i had
this epiphany like wow this actually
really works and it's not putting a
strain on our family it's not putting
strain on me it's just actually
it's just extra money that i was
actually pouring towards a credit card
that i didn't even need to have so i
started to see the snowball effect and
it really got me pumped that's awesome
yeah and then and then we had another
issue um
early april our cat got sick we had to
put some money into him but then april
6th he uh we put him to sleep
morning of april 7th i get a phone call
from her and i'm at work and i've said
you know she's probably still upset
um
she go i answer the phone and she says i
just got let go from my job due to covid
so 2020 was really hard for us and i
honestly it was a blessing um thank you
god because of the fact that we paid
those credit cards off so if we didn't
pay that little extra bit before going
into 2020 we would have been in a very
dire situation like how do we pay for
our house
day care um but honestly it was a dis
like a blessing in disguise
so
um
a couple months you know she got a
severance that helped cover things a
couple months went by she got another
job
ended up being
it was work from home but it was fairly
toxic work environment yeah
her boss was kind of bullying her a
little bit and so she ended up quitting
that after a few months
um
two three months go by which finally
gets another job as a recruiter
uh
but a job that she had interviewed for
previously
got in contact with her after she took
that job and it's the one that she
wanted well she ended up leaving that to
take the one she has now yeah and you
know it was about a 75
pay raise where she was at the beginning
of the year yeah she ended the year yeah
and on top of that um we pushed our
daughter into kindergarten she was right
on the cusp to start first or
kindergarten and so when we got her in
there we didn't have to pay for daycare
which was another mortgage payment so
that really that severance pay um and
the extra money from the daycare we were
just pushing it towards any debt that we
had because honestly that was money
already being taken out of our pockets
why would we just keep it in our in our
pockets to spend miscellaneous on
missing lands things yeah absolutely so
i i was just telling cat like you know
in 2020 you would think we wouldn't be
able to pay all this debt but think
about it in 25 months that is including
2020 yeah and it's including 2021 and we
were able to pay all that so it's
amazing yeah and you went through all
kinds of ups and downs and dipsy doodles
to get there it wasn't easy but it
definitely uh it got me the opportunity
that i waited patiently for the dream
job um that i always prayed for and
asked for
that's amazing you guys so
through that i mean obviously there were
some hard spots what would you say was
the thing that kept you going like that
secret thing
out there that people are like wow they
did all that in two years like what's
the secret what's the thing well for me
it's just getting on the same page with
her because you know that whole time
before
we were just i was paying myself my own
student loans yeah and then we combine
and it's you know when you put the power
of the two incomes together you can
really yes make it happen i always say
for me is one me praying and being
grateful and content with what i have we
didn't live outside of our means
and second to just stick with it and see
it through like i said i was paying 70
on one credit card in a hundred
for what and once i paid that 70 off i
had i could literally be like let's go
and spend it on eating out and so forth
but i didn't i put it towards the 100
and 170 pay that credit card off within
three months instead of like oh the
seven or eight months that i like
projected to pay off so
stick with it see it through and see
that snowball effect it actually
it's amazing because it just pushed me
to do more it's awesome that's awesome
it's the momentum of getting those it
does wins and you're like okay i'm going
to keep going i want to keep going you
don't want to stop that extra money that
we all paid off a debt literally is now
it's not money out of our pockets yeah
at all it's actually saving for our new
house and it's not like a strain on us
like most people would think it was like
no that money was from that 70 credit
card first paid up that 100 off that 15
000 car you know it all collected up and
i just i wish that like my friends would
see like this is what happened that's
always that you're at your largest
wealth building tool is your income and
when you actually get to keep your
income instead of it going back out to
the 70 the 100 the car right it's like
you said it's yours it's like oh this is
actually my money that i can use to do
what i want so that's amazing you guys
congratulations thank you well done
proud of you thank you good work
and you brought your daughter along to
scream with you what is her name and age
you wanna bring her up into the shot yep
this is haley and she is six years old
hi haley so sweet she's so pretty with
those teeth i love it
i love it that's perfect good stuff all
right we've got a copy of baby steps
millionaires for you because that's the
next chapter in your story a copy total
money makeover for you to give away
and uh this week we started giving away
also financial peace university and
every dollar is a part of ramsey plus a
one-year subscription to that
and you can either use all of these
yourself or you can give them away as
gifts or however you want to do it we
want to help you certainly total money
makeover you can give away because
you've already lived that part of it and
on with the next chapters of life well
done you guys we're proud of you thank
you
you're amazing well done beautiful
beautiful family good stuff all right
it's robert and crystal and haley
75 000 paid off in 25 months making 87
to 130 count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream
three two one
[Music]
[Applause]
way to go you guys
beautiful stuff awesome
you know she
with great enthusiasm explained the debt
snowball perfectly yep you know when you
pay off that little debt and you take
that money and you throw it on the next
one you take that money and throw it on
the next one then you take that money
and throw it on the next one every time
you pay off another death the snowball
rolls over more money and there's more
money going on but also there's more
excitement yes because you get to see
this benefit of this thing moving and
you're actually getting traction and
this whole money thing is working for
the first time in your life you're
working with your spouse for the first
time in your life there's a lot going on
there
well done you guys we're proud of you
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is the ramsey show my co-host is
rachel cruz ramsey personality number
one
best-selling author
rachel we always have some good
discussions when you're on here you and
i sometimes arguing and sometimes just
discussing something that's going on in
the world
and
always bringing you and i bringing
different perspectives to things yes
well
james the producer emailed what probably
two weeks ago
and was like isn't this crazy this
played literally one year ago this clip
so i watch it
and
during i'll say this during some of our
debates
you know a question like um dave he
doesn't he doesn't really you don't
really know he doesn't really get it
he's really missing the mark here on
this one he doesn't he doesn't see it
but on this clip specifically as i
watched it again a year later i thought
he's brilliant
he's like
who was like the old sidekick that was
like 800 the 1-800 number uh miss clia
or yeah is that what it was she got
arrested but she didn't know it was
coming so she wasn't a psychic
i was watching i was like is dave
psychic okay so what we're going to play
for you is the clip psycho that's it
maybe both
uh that played
it played april 27th of 2021 okay we got
to get back everyone get back in your
mindset of 2021
of early 2021 okay the pan i mean steph
is still here
you know you're still wearing a mask on
airplanes covid was still like tr it was
still kind of all kind of around the
idea of it uh gas just started going up
car prices i do not think at this point
were outrageous the car thing had not
happened yet
again martin was barely in office yes so
again we are sitting one year ago um
basically today when this segment aired
so we're gonna play just a little bit of
it and we're gonna watch uh mrs clia do
her do her magic
have you felt this ever i mean for four
years i've never seen it like this
exactly yeah but uh in 19 in the 19 uh
what we are going to see out of this
that you've never seen your generation's
ever seen is inflation
inflation the components that make up
the inflation index housing is one of
them it's the biggest part of inflation
and when housing shoots up and oil
shoots up
and oil has shot up too yeah it has yeah
and uh you know you look at the gas pump
oh yeah oh i know i filled up my minivan
two days ago nobody's talking nobody's
talking about it but the gas pump
doubles and housing goes up a bunch then
all of a sudden you're going to see
stuff like i saw in the 70s and 80s
which was double digit inflation where
stuff's going up 10 15 a year
and inflation was out of control and the
politicians it took it you know it took
some real
strong
politicians to do away with it uh it was
out of control how do they do away with
it well i
i credit ronald reagan i'm just put the
brakes on because it was out of control
under carter and he comes in and shifted
economic policy and uh just started
opening up uh doing away with regulation
opening up the markets because if you
can flood the market with supply
it slows down as flows down the feeding
frenzy because if you can get it
everywhere there's no scarcity sure then
the prices start to settle
you know if there's an oversupply prices
go down if there's an under supply
prices go up
because there's people chasing it sure
it's a plan demanding you know few you
know half the number of people chasing
it as there are you know you got two
houses for sale for every buyer
while the sudden prices stabilize start
to go down start to or at least quit
shooting through the roof so the out of
control upward inflation so we're
probably going to see some actual
inflation out of this which we've not
seen in two decades you watch these
interest rates go up with inflation yeah
it'll shut this housing market down i
was going to say how yeah the
correlation between inflation and the
interest if you go from three to six
this housing market will freeze like a
deer in the headlights it'll just stop
people just stop buying they'll just
back up and wait
and uh that's you're going to see some
of that back and forth now it's going to
be a little rocky
a little volatile but it won't this
feeding frenzy that you've got right
this second is not going to continue
we're talking about the housing market
going into that okay so you predicted
inflation you were like inflation's
going to happen your generation's never
seen it before but it will happen and i
remember thinking
oh
doomsday dave i don't know i don't know
if it'll happen inflation has happened
and then you predicted
that the interest rates for mortgages
will go up and now they're up to five
percent they've gone up in the last few
months so like inflation hit mortgage
price mortgage interest is going up
what
what's gonna happen next are we heading
for a recession predict the recession
predict it right now are we going to
recession but seriously is that all
crazy though that you
that well the signs were there it's not
i'm not no i know i know those things
are happening the components of
inflation were already kicking in we
were seeing prices jump through the roof
on things and the biden administration
on the things it could do things about
wasn't for instance energy it the stuff
at the gas pump is his fault the other
parts of inflation the the republicans
are trying to blame him for it's nice
fault it's pandemic's fault it was a
supply demand curve thing and so fox
news wearing biden out you know because
they're trying to get gop in at
uh
at the uh um
the midterms right so it's political on
blaming him for it but anyway the um
you know and and we are probably going
to see six percent i said we go from
three to six on mortgages and then i
said the housing market would freeze
like a deer in the headlights it will
it'll it'll it won't it won't go down
it's not going to be like 2008 i'm not
predicting it to go down but you know
two years ago in 2022 we had a 32
increase
in the cost of housing in america the
next year we had a 17 increase the
average increase over the years is about
four percent
and the reason for that is very simple
shortage of houses new houses yes
there's 10 buyers 20 buyers for every
house that's on the market and when
you've got those kinds of pressures
you're going to have an artificial
inflation it's a supply demand curve
inflation it's not a thing it's not a
prosperity type inflation it's not a the
economy is too heated up
thing but you know when people slow down
buying houses it will slow down the rate
of increase in houses they're not going
to go down i'm going to wait on real
estate values to come down you're going
to be you're going to be dead before
they come back down they're not coming
down they're just they're not going to
go up at 32 percent a year yeah and this
idea of 400 people bidding on one house
over the weekend stuff that's going to
go away because when you double the cost
of interest your payment on
on a 400 000 house goes up dramatically
sure okay so what yes so those two
percentage points
is get from three percent to five
percent yeah
it's getting devalued the bond market
like 35
the bond market is crashing with these
increases in interest and the market is
the market has gone down stock market
has gone down yes and that's because the
economy is slowing that's that's
recessionary okay so so the gdp
came out gross domestic product came out
down
over the first quarter and if it goes
down two quarters in a row it's a
reception so so we could be entering a
recession at the end of this quarter if
it continues to go down yeah we probably
will and you think we'll probably hit a
recession yeah i think i think we're in
one yeah i think we're right square in
the middle i don't know how long it'll
last but it depends on how long they
keep monkeying with stuff in washington
yeah but um
you know they could have done a lot to
help the supply demand curve stuff like
getting the ships off the ocean
you know when you got billions of
dollars of goods sitting in the ocean
waiting to come on shore and you can't
get baby formula that's a false thing
caused by regulations and crap
okay get the stuff out of the cartons
and get it in the stores it's not and so
there's some stuff that that the policy
makers and the politicians can actually
do that it is their fault okay so the
recession word is a scary word for a lot
of people because last time we hit that
was during the oak crowd all of that
right so you hear the word recession
recession simply means the economy is
not producing as much goods and services
as it used to and it can affect you
mainly it will affect your jobs
because the businesses that are not
growing do not hire
and businesses that are shrinking fire
they lay off uh it's not it's not
pandemic furloughs they say you know
economics are bad i have to show you
know we're we're laying you off
permanently that's what they'll do
and so there'll be some people losing
jobs so we've had this shortage of labor
we've got almost no unemployment rate so
bizarre it's like the weirdest it's the
weirdest mix it's a weird weird weird
gumbo and so but but
the stock market is slowing because
profits are down because the economy is
slowing even though prices are up yes
but people are spending not spending as
much as they were even six months ago
right we know that because their economy
is shrinking because there is not stuff
to buy
there's not stuff to buy
they're fearful
consumers pull back yeah probably i
don't know but recession is not an
emotional thing and it's really honestly
it's um
it's kind of a natural second step
after a bizarre you know supply demand
inflation curve like this yeah so so
will inflation go down
once the recession or that's all yeah
it'll kind of work inflation will go
down when the supplies hit the market
comes back yep in each area you know
stuff's going to stop shooting up when
there's plenty of stuff yes you know
there's plenty of cars cars will go down
but there's still not plenty of cars
there's still a shortage yeah you know
so that that's what's driving that so
inflation is not a feat our recession is
not a feeling
it is
two consecutive quarters of a shrinking
economy
this you know it's not a feeling it's
just gonna it is a thing that's gonna
happen though this is the ramsey show
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsay show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host rachel cruz
ramsey personality is my co-host we help
people build wealth do work that they
love
and create amazing actual
relationships this is the ramsey show
the phone number is triple eight eight
two five five two two five mary's in
hartford connecticut hi mary welcome to
the ramsay show
hi dave thank you for taking my call and
thank you rachel for for listening in on
on this too
so my question my husband and i are in
our early 60s and thank you that to you
and and to your plan that we paid off
200 000
um in two years by selling things but we
we were debt-free january 1 of this year
wonderful thank you so much for that
wonderful yeah my my question because we
hope to retire in the next two or three
years
um i'm nervous about investing in my
401k because every time i turn around
it's going down and down and down should
i use that money instead
just temporarily does help pay off our
mortgage
no
how old are you mary 60s early 60s oh so
no yeah early 60s yeah i thought you
said 36 no early 60s
um and we make it would you make a good
income we're about 300k um before tax
how much is in your 401k
i have
um last i looked it was
389 000. okay what's your total nest egg
and
husbands yours everybody's
um well we have 43 000 in our emergency
fund
um we have probably about another 30 000
in savings and
checking
and and that's it
your 401k is the only one your husband
doesn't have one
that's right that's right you have a
penny in our in our home
i have a small product does he
have a pension no he does he does not
have a pension okay so you've got four
let's just call it four hundred thousand
dollars and how much is your mortgage
okay
um our what we have left on our mortgage
is three hundred and fifteen thousand
zillow has i just looked at zillow and
it is estimated to almost a million
which is crazy amazes me but it was yeah
so you're a millionaire 195 000. your
baby step man
right but i'm
nervous about i i don't want to retire
with the mortgage yeah good i don't want
you to retire with a mortgage either so
um let's lay out a plan on the mortgage
for a second uh how far how many years
more are the two of you going to work
before you want to how many years have
we got to pay off the mortgage
well i would i would like to be able to
retire in two years and and perhaps for
my husband another four years okay and
how much of the 300 does he make
he makes
250. oh he makes the majority of the
income
yes yes yes okay and so in four years if
you paid off 75 000 a year out of 300
income the mortgage would be paid off
right
yes
yeah
without having to touch with that and
you can still put 15 of your income into
retirement and baby step four
but i want you to put on your your magic
cat again and predict me when the
market's going to rise up again i i
can't but the market's not crashing
the market is down 5
in the last 12 months
5
5 is not going to keep you from retiring
as a matter of fact it means that you're
at the store and they just announced a
sale over the intercom
the shirt you wanted to buy is on sale
mary
this is not the time to not buy the
shirt
all right
the stock market's not when it's down
five percent it's on sale you don't want
to buy it when it's up you want to buy
it when it's down
okay
all right it's still it's still scary
it is scary but let's understand five
percent
of 400 000 down is not gonna cause you
to be able to retire or not be able to
retire you don't have a five percent
issue
okay if you have a 50 issue if your 400
went to 200
like if you're invested in bitcoin it's
down 50 percent
yeah and you're 400 which you're not
crazy so you didn't do that but i mean
if you you would be down to nothing
right
i mean and you'd be down to half and so
we're not talking about that we're
talking about five percent and five
percent of four hundred thousand dollars
is eight thousand bucks
it looks a lot bigger when i look at my
statements it looks a lot bigger when
you listen to the news
the news is going to the right wing news
is gonna do everything they can to talk
about how horrible the economy is until
the fall
because they're trying to get the
democrats thrown out of office
and they're then the biggest thing that
can get a politician thrown out of
office is the economy so they're going
to talk about inflation they're going to
talk about recession they're going to
talk about high gases they're going to
talk about high interest rates they're
going to talk about how horrible things
are and the stock market is crashing
and they're going to you if you keep if
you keep the right wing news on you're
going to see that from now until fall
every it's going to be a steady beat of
that for the next six months
you're going to get a diet of it and
it's going to drive you bananas i'll
turn it off and if you watch the
left-wing news they lie about it on the
other way so
these things that that you know the
right wings are saying are true
but they're they're overstated like when
a tornado is coming through they tell
everybody they're gonna die
it's the same thing because they're
trying to get ratings
okay but let me say this though when she
does look at the statement
and she sees oh that's what we lost like
it is it's a punch in the gut yeah so
mary though but what i would encourage
you is you know well she's close to
retirement so she is looking she's got
she's not going to use the four hundred
dollars that's what i was going to say
though is that at that point you kind of
just put it away
and not sit there in this like rat race
cycle that you have
let it play out because you're gonna
still be in the market
for another you know that's a good point
you're not going to use the 400 when you
retire yeah you're just going to live
off the income increase right
and so if it's up 8 000 or down 8 000 it
doesn't matter just keep it okay and so
watching the statement month in a month
out i'm 61. i don't look at my statement
not because i'm emotionally incapable of
doing it but i just don't bother because
i'm really not going to use that money
right now and the current problems in
the world are not going to bother me one
way or another because that money i'm
not going to use it right now mary's in
the same situation she's not going to
use that money she's going to use the
income off of that money right
and so i would be more concerned
for her
if i thought the 500 000 or 600 or 700
000 that'll be by the time they get to
retirement
would not create an income for them yes
if the uh if there was not good returns
on that to live off of the returns
of that money that would concern me more
yes than the actual
amount going up or down five percent
it's how much income will it create over
time that's what i'm worried about
that's a that's a good way of
understanding it but yeah mary it's
normal to do this i i just i really turn
off the news and i quit looking at your
statement every month and it's not to be
ignorant but it's your it's driving you
nuts
and uh it would probably drive me nuts
actually i don't i had to turn off the
news and i don't look at my statements
so there you go this is
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host guys if you're wondering whether
to buy or sell a home this year we got
some answers you can expect the market
to be a lot like last year
well prices will still be on the rise
interest rates are headed up it may slow
down a little bit
if you're buying a home you can be up
against some heavy competition still
you're definitely going to be up against
a heavy hefty price tag compared to
three years ago plus higher interest
rates means higher mortgage payments you
really need to stick to your budget
to win in any market
you got to know what you're doing and
you need to work with someone who knows
what they're doing
uh this is not amateur hour in the real
estate world you need a pro
in your corner walking with you advising
you teaching you our endorsed local
provider program will lead you to a real
estate agent that is the best in the
business as ramsey trusted pros they
care about your values keeping more of
your money in your pocket and really not
being crazy and just doing something
that'll get you it gets you hurt later
just in the name of buying a house
ramsey solutions dot com slash agent
that's where you can find the elp the
endorsed local provider for real estate
that's ramsey trusted in your area
ramsey solutions dot com slash agent our
question of the day comes from
blinds.com they have a 100 satisfaction
guarantee that means even if you
mismeasure you pick the wrong color
they'll remake your blinds for free you
get free samples free shipping and with
the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more use the promo code
ramsey to get the best deal today's
question comes from lucas in maryland i
am currently on in baby step two working
on paying off the remainder of our
student loan debt
we have paid at 69 000 but have a
balance of 38 000 we paid off our home
we make a hundred thousand a year i have
an extensive firearm collection
that i could sell off a portion of and
pay it off tomorrow but i'm hesitant to
do that
as i am afraid i wouldn't be able to
replace many of them
should i sell them to pay off the debt
tomorrow
or keep moving the way i am and pay it
off by december
i don't know firearms are kind of in
your uh in your bucket of life i'm not
sure how much i could speak into that
uh
i have an extensive having extensive
purse collection
there we go now we'll make it make it
real all right all right you're working
with me okay uh
i mean i don't know i would be i would
be interested in your take on this
because for me i'm like okay you make a
hundred grand a year you have 38 000
and you have a plan paid off by december
you could just keep trucking along easy
enough yeah easy enough to pay it off
without having the thing i would do is
this in any collection i have and i'm a
collector of things oh we know i have an
ocd
side to me i collect used water skis i
collect firearms i've got
i'm just like i get i get off on
something i go down the whole rabbit
hole and don't get out so collector
hoarder
so anyway the um
this is not about me
uh so what i would tell you though as
one firearm guy or another guy that has
an extensive collection
i don't know what you mean by extensive
collection okay if you have an extensive
collection that is worth
uh
three hundred thousand dollars
okay
and you can sell off ten percent of it
and pay this off today
you probably have ten percent of stuff
around the edges of that collection that
you don't care that much about
that's not in the sweet spot
those are not your babies you know
they're not safe queens as we call them
and so um the uh
you know you but but you know if your
entire collection is eighty thousand
dollars and you'll be selling half of it
then you're probably cutting out a
little bit of your heart
when you do that so i think that's what
you gotta ask yourself and just say okay
is it worth it
is there some of these items that i care
more about being dead on being out of
debt on than i do the other way i will
tell you this
if if the numbers were different if it
was going to be an extended period of
time yes i don't care three years yeah i
i'd be selling your stuff man yeah yep
and uh i will never forget in financial
peace university years ago when i was
teaching it live with an overhead
projector this big old guy is a
linebacker looking guy completely ripped
probably you know 260 pounds muscles
everywhere
blonde had a guy
a country boy uh he and his little bitty
nurse wife were sitting there
and she starts telling the group
what her husband had done to get out of
debt and she's just
crying
and i'm like what in the world
and she said he has had this knife
collection
that was his prize most prized
possession
and um he sold it for 12 000 and we paid
off all of our debt last week because he
loves he he said i love you and my kids
more than i love my knife wow
and what that spoke to her that it just
screamed at her i love you mm-hmm and
and the whole place is just like
giving him a standing ovation because
that's a man yeah that's a that's a
grown-up who will sacrifice for the good
of their family
for their future and it's just stuff so
in that sense if these numbers were
different lucas i would be putting you
in that category and saying dude sell
your guns yeah yeah
sell your guns they're just guns i mean
it's just fun but you you've got the
income your debt-free house and
everything you're down to the last 38
000. you're going to get there pretty
quick anyway
so i'm not it's a different discussion
and with the same thing be for like a
like i remember being on the show i
think i was with ken maybe when we were
hosting and a guy had a collector car
that he just loved love love loved and
he's like i could sell and be out of
debt today or i could be out of debt
again there's some situations like that
some collector cars okay my dad and i
rebuilt this mustang 500 hours when i
was 14 through 17 years old i'm 42.
you don't sell that car that's like
selling your wedding ring
yeah okay i wouldn't ask you to sell
your wedding ring either to get out of
debt
but uh i bought this car a few years ago
and it's kind of fun
you sell that car yeah yeah
you know if you're in if you're in if
you've got yourself into a mess because
you've you know you gave up the right to
own something like that because you'd
already spent the money yes and so yeah
so but there's some things that have
some nostalgic value or if in this
firearms collection was a musket from
his great-grandfather
that he used you know to protect the
fort or what i don't know you know like
whatever you whatever you can you don't
sell that gun okay that's a family
heirloom that's not a it's not a
collection item unless it doesn't mean
much to you and it's a family heirloom
that's just sitting there and you're
like i don't really you don't sell that
gun because you'll wake up later and
it'll mean something to you if it's
that that's that you know like well my
wedding ring doesn't mean that much to
me yeah you're gonna regret that don't
do that that's just that that's gonna
come you're you're a little bit too
enthused about getting out of debt right
now you need to calm down about one
notch you know no no i mean really you
don't sell your weapons gazelle has
slowed down well you don't the gazelle
doesn't sell its wedding ring it just
runs okay
don't stop and sell your wedding ring
keep running but yeah
no it's good it's a good that's good i'm
somebody's gonna send me little cartoons
of gazelles with what i'm so mad at you
they're people are so mad at you no but
it's a good
it's a good um
because i feel like getting out of debt
is not a balanced thing you're not
balanced when you're gonna add that you
are doing everything humanly possible
to get out of debt it's that intensity
and the more you sacrifice the faster
you're going to do it and there's that
final one that's crazy in that yes you
plug in that small human element and say
okay
what's worth it okay there used to be a
lady there used to be a lady that had a
newsletter back when there were paper
newsletters that uh her way of getting
money was she she didn't ever buy
anything she went and got in dumpsters
and got stuff out of dumpsters dumpster
diving okay
i'm not doing that
and i'm not recommending people do that
okay if you want to do it i'm not mad at
you but that's like homeless people
stuff okay i'm not dumpster diving
because to get out of debt that's that
last one percent of crazy yeah yeah yeah
and i'm not going in the left or like
we're gonna sell our house
i'm gonna put you up on 99 crazy but i'm
not going into the last one
and that's selling the wedding ring
selling the car that your dad and you
rebuilt for 500 hours when you were 14.
that's uh
selling a family heirloom or a special
place or in this case it's a short
period of time that you're gaining yeah
an uber short period of time
and so it's it you know i'm not going to
sell something that's hard to replace a
lot of guns you can get another one
depending on what it is but if you've
got a unique piece that's probably one
or you know one of 50 or something
you're probably not going to find that
one again
these aren't guns you shoot people these
are collectibles yeah and so um
uh but that's you know
that that's good
yep i think it's great it's a balanced
approach and it's good hearing that
perspective because
it gives a lot because we all have
something like that right it's like that
human element so it's good great
question lucas appreciate you writing in
to us brother this is the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
thanks for joining us america rachel
cruz ramsey personality is my co-host
emily is in rhode island hi emily
welcome to the show
hi dave and rachel thanks for having me
sure um so my question for you today is
um i'm in the sixth year of my career
and i've worked at the same company all
six years and just found out that we are
being acquired
um so i'm wondering what to do with my
401k i'm i'm keeping my job nobody's
being laid off or anything but i have a
401k that i'm wondering
if i should move over to the new
company's 401k plan or i can roll it
over to an ira i would roll it to an ira
okay yeah get with the smart investor
pro at ramseysolutions.com
find one in your area that has the heart
of a teacher you'll select the mutual
funds that you want in your ira
and when you fill out that paperwork
they you will fill out another piece of
paper that allows for a direct transfer
they will send that to your company your
company will send the money directly to
the mutual fund
do not let them write you a check
okay the reason is they have to withhold
twenty percent if they write you a check
and then you have tax problems because
you have to put it you have to roll over
100 or you get into taxes but if you
just roll it there's no taxes no money
changes hands it just moves from the old
401 k into your thing so it's under your
control there's 8 000 mutual funds to
choose from and in your new 401 k
there'll just be a handful of mutual
funds to choose from
and they may be good ones but that's
different if her company was bought
it's bought which makes it just like
she's changing jobs from a 401k
standpoint okay
and so her old 401k is freed up she's
allowed to do with it what she wants you
can't move a 401k while you still work
at a company
but this company you're not working for
anymore because you're working for the
new company and so it releases your 401k
and gets you going in the right
direction
so yeah that's exactly what i would do
you want to do when you leave a company
or when you have the opportunity to get
a hold of your money put it in your
control because you have more options
and you are in control
and uh then you just start your new 401k
with your new company and you'll come
out better off because you've got it out
there but you got no taxes on this if
you do the direct transfer rollover and
a smart vester pro can show you how to
do that sean is with us in cincinnati
hey sean how are you
hey good how are you dave great how can
i help
all right so we just started doing the
baby steps correctly about six months
ago we're in baby step three and we so
my wife is three months pregnant i'm
sorry nine months pregnant with our
third son oh wow
thank you so much so we have 11 000 in
our emergency fund right now
and friday evening uh they were in a car
accident everybody's doing fine wow
that's scary
it was super scary nine months much
pregnant a car accident ouch yeah yeah
it was it was intense but everybody's
good together rear-ended um our life's
feeling better baby's fine the boys are
fine but um so our car
it's an o2 blazer lo uh it has 114 000
miles four miles it's a nice car but
insurance is only going to give us about
eleven hundred dollars for it
and i wanted to to know how much
to spend on a
new car a new family car i guess
man so you were driving an 1100 car
yeah i mean
to us it's you know no i'm not asking
about you i'm asking what the car would
sell for
uh the car
so it was totaled out i'm a fire injury
i got that part i'm saying before the
wreck what the car would have sold for
eleven hundred dollars
um uh maybe i'm thinking like five
thousand because we thought about
selling it to
upgrade okay um
because your insurance company has to
give you the market value of the car
okay
not what they want to give you
okay you're under you have a contract
with them called an insurance policy and
they're required to pay you what it
takes to replace the exact car that you
had so the question is what was that car
worth actually what could sue you have
actually sold it for not what it's worth
for you
but if you put it in
you know on trader.com or craigslist
what would it have sold for
so right at about five thousand i saw
something six thousand and why in the
world would you accept eleven hundred
dollars
i i just i've never been in the
situation have you already accepted the
eleven hundred dollars
i have not good
collision company called me and they
said no i'm not taking i'm not taking
eleven hundred dollars okay and here's
the thing you have to make the case
in logic not in feelings
of why that car is actually worth that
here's three other cars for sale on
trader.com that are identical
this car is worth five thousand dollars
if you don't pay me five thousand
dollars i'm gonna get an attorney and
sue your butt
okay so i would go kind of hard nose
with my insurance company
would i contact the
guy who hit us his insurance company at
all or do i well they're the ones that
are supposed to pay it his insurance
company should pay it
okay
they should be making you the offer not
yours
okay perfect yeah they have to replace
your car appreciate it you don't get to
make money on the transaction and i i
love the car and i change the oil and i
don't give a crap about all that what
would the car actually have sold for
before the wreck that's what they need
to write the check for follow me
follow you now once we got that now
let's say we've got three or four
thousand dollars in our pocket let's go
back to your question your question is
what kind of car should we buy did you
say you're in baby step two paying off
debt
no we're in three
okay how much money do you have
we have about 11 000 that includes your
emergency fund
that is our we're building up the
emergency fund okay
this is an emergency yeah yeah yeah i
would take the insurance money and add
three or four thousand to it if i were
in your shoes
okay
and so you're buying probably a seven
eight thousand dollar car something like
that
okay perfect i don't know if i don't
know if this helps uh i just had a girl
on my show talking about cars because
she this is like what she does and she
was talking about how the sedans
that have been built even in the last
eight years the back seat of them can
actually now your trunk space is one
thing but to hold three kids because i
feel like there's this thought out there
once you have three kids you have to
have an suv or you have to have a van
and so even looking at a larger sedan
just for the time period now once now
once a little one's out of a car seat
you know or in a front-facing car seat
all that you may want you're going to
want more room but for the time being
sean you may even look at a sedan
because your suvs and your vans are
naturally going to be more expensive
just to get you guys through this stage
so that's just a thought she mentioned
that on the show and i thought that's a
great point that even some sedans still
are they're built big enough to hold
three in the back it's not gonna be
comfortable it's not ideal but if you
guys need something for now and you
can't find an suv because they're just
so expensive for that price range and
this is just until you you know you
might drive this car six or eight months
yeah
and then because you may you know once
you get your emergency fund back in
place
you may save up and move up again a
little bit in car right
right and that's really so this time
next year you're probably out of the car
that you buy now
okay that's probably where you're at
what's your income
uh about 60. okay all right yeah that's
what i'm gonna do in your case then now
one more time i want to recast okay i'm
not telling you to just be abusive to
the insurance company or to try to take
advantage of them i merely want you to
get what your car was worth and if
you'll approach it with logic like you
had to go into court and prove
to the judge that your car was worth
something you'd have to have evidence
and so like here's three advertisements
in trader.com here's one on craigslist
here's what kelly blue book says the car
was worth
um you know and here's how it was
equipped and you're leaving this off
i've done that in several situations and
increased the settlement in almost every
case because insurance companies are
notorious for lowballing you
okay
on the settlement and so i'm again i'm
not i don't want you get ten thousand
dollars for a car that's worth two that
that's that's immoral i'm not asking
cheat somebody but i am saying you need
to get what's due and the way to
properly negotiate that is to show
actual evidence and and then just tell
them if you guys don't do this the judge
is going to make you do it
and because here's the actual evidence
and if i have to get an attorney those
fees are going to be added on top of it
so let's just do the right thing and
replace my car the guy hit my nine-month
pregnant wife you really don't want to
piss me off here
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today is proverbs 12 11
those who work their land will have
abundant food but those who chase
fantasies
have no sense
abraham lincoln said give me six hours
to chop down a tree and i will spend the
first four sharpening
the axe
there you go
there you go open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five rachel
cruz is my co-host today alex is with us
in utah hi alex welcome to the ramsey
show
hi there dave and rachel thanks for
taking my call sure how can we help
um so i guess sharpening the axe i'm
here trying to plan for the future a
little bit i'm planning on buying a home
in the next couple months
and
i mean i don't really have any need or
desire to live by myself necessarily and
also like to have renters for some
income as well
and i'm just trying to figure out how to
understand
separating the kind of personal expenses
and business expenses for my rental
company rental property
specifically with tithing i've heard you
say before that you know for profit and
lot profits for uh business is what you
would tithe on that you actually like
are given to you as a person that you
take out of the company um but on the
personal side it seems like you
typically tithe just anything that's
coming to you as your income and so i
guess i'm just trying to understand how
you might separate that out with
something like a property that kind of
serves both a personal purpose as well
as a business purpose
i'm not sure i mean if you rent out to
roommates what your expenses that are
deductible are
if you're living in another part of the
house
uh yeah so i mean it'd be things you
know like utilities hoa fees homeowners
insurance yeah i guess a percentage of
those it wouldn't it wouldn't be 100 but
you know whatever the square footage
let's say you're renting out uh 20 of
your house then 20 of your hoa fee would
be deductible as an expense i guess and
so um
i guess you would you probably just keep
a little spreadsheet on that honestly
and say you know i'm
charging whatever 1 500 bucks or
whatever you're charging and uh here's
my expenses and here's my net profit per
month
and that's also going to be for your
taxes
as well to calculate your income tax
and then
would with other expenses that are you
know
deductible or whether or not it's a
business something like you know your
mortgage insurance um your interest
property taxes with those kind of things
that normally if it was just my own
house i would
tithe whatever my income was and then
pay for that anyway yeah and then i
would just
consider that the same way yeah i i
always just say whatever is taxable
or whatever i can charge off as a
business expense
you know creates the taxable income
and your mortgage interest is not
deductible
uh in in terms of against your uh
as well the interest is a deductible the
payment is not deductible so if you want
if you want to charge it off and then
charge off part of it and you want to
keep it for tax purposes
that's an easy way to to calculate your
tithe
if you're being real technical about the
tithe
um
uh honestly in that situation if i was
doing all that calculation just to
figure out the tithe yeah i would just
wet finger in the air and then add some
to it because you can't mess up being
too generous
and uh so i didn't fool with the math
but if you're going to do all the math
for tax purposes anyway then just use
that number
for your tithe your taxable income
before you pay taxes on it is what i
tithe on and uh you can
do a bible study a lot of different ways
and argue about this and all that and i
i'm not gonna argue about it it's god
wants people to be generous he wants us
to those of us that are followers of
christ to
uh be giving
and steadily giving and a tithe is an
indicator of how to do that
but i i don't spend a lot of not
legalistic about it i don't get
legalistic about it i i give a lot more
than a tithe uh to to uh local church
and to various ministries and various
things through our foundation so i'm not
worried about you know whether i made it
or not you know kind of thing
and and so um because i just just
because i believe generosity is a
spiritual principle
uh but but if you want to do all the
calculation you know just to make you
know to feel feel
like you're doing it correctly there's
nothing wrong with doing that it's not a
bad spiritual exercise
uh to do that but you might as well use
it for your taxes anyway if you're gonna
do all that anthony's in houston hey
anthony welcome to the ramsay show all
right how are you guys doing great how
can we help
uh so i've just got a question i don't
really know where to go from where i'm
at i don't have any debt i've got two
credit cards but i don't want to cancel
him because it'll kill my credit and i
don't really have a problem just letting
them sit there
i mean what should my next steps be
would it be down payment an emergency
fund or
how should i work it yeah it's a good
question well number one you know we
we're not that concerned about the
credit score honestly anthony because
you can still get a mortgage without a
credit score using manual underwriting
and then most of the time why you need a
credit score is to go deeper in debt so
we're not too worried about the credit
score over here so we would advise
and i would say just yeah i would go
ahead and just cancel it out cancel the
credit cards get them off the plate
and then start saving for your fully
funded emergency fund of three to six
months of expenses you're going to keep
borrowing money anthony
no
well you need a credit score for
okay fair enough
and
my girlfriend who i do plan to marry has
enough saved up to be our emergency fund
so could i take advantage of that and
just
go full board towards down payment on a
property i would just start saving i
would say for your own emergency fund
and then when you guys do actually get
married then you guys will have a lot of
money saved and you can allocate some of
it to an emergency fund
but you don't have to decide that today
just have a big old pile of money yeah i
would i would keep i mentally would keep
it separate anthony um from her just to
say hey here's my here's my baby steps
what i'm doing she can do hers and then
when you guys get married you can buy it
all and then you'll have a huge jump
start which is awesome because you'll
probably have your fully funded
emergency fund and a great down payment
once you guys get married
mark is with us in daytona beach hey
mark welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave hi rachel thanks for taking my
call sure what's up uh dave i'm a
federal employee i'm an air traffic
controller for the faa and uh my wife
and i are baby steps four five and six
i contribute to the roth tsp
um
i don't know if you know or not that air
traffic controllers are required by law
to retire at 56 and yep so in the
government's infinite wisdom they won't
let me touch that money it's home 59 and
a half right um
high stress job now
yeah do what i said a high stress job
yeah that's what i hear um
so as of right now we have a pension i'm
you know i'm eligible to retire in a
little less than 11 years i'm forced to
retire in a little less than 17 years
i don't want to say that i'm banking on
having that pension yeah would be nice
but do you have any other
recommendations of somebody in a unique
situation such as myself yes
as of not
maybe putting some money towards
traditional as correct as opposed to all
of it towards the world it's called it's
called bridge
investing
and it's investing to bridge between 56
and 59
and to have a nest egg that will do that
and it's just simple mutual fund
investing uh so we tell folks to put 15
away in baby step four you're probably
aware of that right
right in your case i would take 10 of
that 15 how much have you gotten your
tsp now
uh
i try not to look at it as a late i
think probably
between 180 and 200 and then we have
another 100 or so and you got 17 years
to go
yeah yeah okay so you're gonna have
seven eight hundred thousand dollars in
there if you don't add anything to it
if you're in the c the s and the i like
we teach people to do
and you're gonna be adding to it because
i'm gonna tell you to keep putting five
percent of your income in there but i'm
gonna take 10 percent of your income and
build a really nice nest egg outside of
the tsp
and uh get in touch with one of our
smart investor pros and they can help
you do that there's some processes and
mutual funds you can use that have just
come out in the last few years that
allow you to invest
in capital gains oriented low turnover
type mutual funds where you don't pay
taxes on the growth unless you pull it
out
and so you can just roll it in let it
grow let it grow let it grow let it grow
you're looking for those types of things
you need a tax advantaged
type mutual fund low turnover ratio type
mutual fund talk to one of our smart
investor pros and they can help you do
that it's called bridge investing to do
this good call mark good call and thanks
for keeping us safe in the air that puts
this hour the rams you show in the books
we'll be back with you before you know
it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
prince of peace christ jesus if you want
to do your debt-free scream live on the
show visit ramseysolutions.com
debt free screen we'd love for you to
come to nashville and tell dave your
story that's ramsey solutions.com
debt free screen
[Music]
you